[Music]
stop all talks of politics and anything
really important we got some actual [ __ ]
going on let's go this is where mine
should be what is it and it's in wichita
kansas wichita oh i met some guys from
kansas the other day yeah three of them
or five of them
uh they're really nice and i didn't know
white people and asians were friends
like that what do you mean there was a
group of i think like three white guys
three asian guys i'm like that's kind of
cool oh
i don't know maybe i thought in kansas i
thought in kansas they would be like get
out of chiang chong whatever in pink but
then they're actually like friends so
is it the missouri side kansas or the
kansas side kansas i don't know i'm just
ignoring myself
the only thing i know about kansas is
from ozark they have the kansas city mob
but you got to watch out for those guys
because they don't want darlene to be
selling their heroine yep darlene
darlene snail exactly did you finish it
oh no no i still got a couple episodes
all right i've been finished that talk
about that later that's all i know
breakdown episode i got to get back on
it it's so good
ozark's a great documentary
so here's what's happening in wichita
kansas police are searching for and may
have even identified
a serial [ __ ] must be the kansas city
mob
it's a woman
who is caught on multiple cameras at
different beauty stores [ __ ] onto
wigs
oh so inside the store she would go on
wigs during business hours during
business hours she'd go into the store
she would she would take wigs
and just [ __ ] in them and everyone's
just standing there like what are you
doing well they wouldn't know until she
was shooting so when you try on the wig
you'd be like oh my gosh it's a little
poo poo head
it's a little warm on my head i don't
know okay she's taking it to the
bathroom and pooping on them she doesn't
take it to the bathroom just shits on
them whether it's where they're sitting
yeah but are people like what are you
doing yeah because you think about the
process that's why she strikes you know
in with the cloud of darkness or
something she's confident when she walks
in there she's like oh look at these
wigs you need to know the legit she
probably has another one is like looking
at it while she's [ __ ] in one and
then she's like oh yeah they thought at
first that maybe she was taking it to
the bathroom because they were out of
toilet paper or something but is there a
dressing room for wigs
no like a wigging room
so like when you see different shelves
like a beauty supply and like let's say
some of the shelves have wigs that are
more in the back or something and she's
taking a little stroll she just grabs
the wig takes a dump puts it back
as quickly as that i'm assuming she's
not wiping oh no she is wiping uh with
the wig she's probably got one loaded
would you want she just keeps doing this
and so the police in that area uh
they were they on their facebook they
posted like a
a search for her and they called her
public enemy number two
that's good
and they also named her the pooper
trader
yes and uh hopes that someone could find
her her timing must be good because
she's got to be like like just sitting
in the car or something like
all right i feel like
that's
yeah it was me i would have to like drop
it like 7 30 a.m on the dot every
morning it's like if i'm gonna poop on a
wig it needs to be at 7 30.
i'm going to shoot blanks like at what
point in her life did she probably been
doing it for a while then no it's not
that weird no way it's not that weird
well it's not weird i think that you
should do it on stuff yeah dude remember
uh mtv true life like i'm addicted to
pooping on wigs or something like that
or i'm in love with my car
yeah dude people are weird man wait that
was a real episode moving on wait oh no
i just i mean
there's a dude that had sex with his car
oh yeah the tailpipe and the other the
some chick that love to eat styrofoam or
cotton or something right like girls
yeah the one that likes to bathe in
bleach and all that weird stuff it's
crazy
there's one that like to drink his own
pee
and he would do it he owned a machida he
would have a cheetah he would he would
pee in a neti pot and then like drink it
that way through the number that way
sometimes
did that no not leona
leota did on record drink his pee though
he's a famous mma fighter that used to
drink his pee does that mean his
brothers and his dad does it too i i
think there's a video of him i think
it's called urine therapy you're in
you're in therapy or whatever yeah i'm a
little low can you spot me i don't know
what a fair prize is but
i'm gonna unfollow his brother
shinzo yeah because he teaches karate
for mma i like it i like seeing his
stuff but they're not anymore
on the facebook page for the police they
said thank you for all your calls and
reports but it is not amber heard we
have confirmed that
so they're just using this to make a
bunch of poop jokes they just have a
really good sense of humor places that
are not cali yeah
no dude the uh the uh like all the state
agencies are like on social media now
like likes like state pds chps and stuff
like that because i have to follow them
all and they're like cracking jokes on
people like putting people on blast like
hey next time don't drink and drive
maybe you'll be alive or something like
that dead dude i mean i made that part
yeah the guys on the cement all bla
bleeding tell them jokes and [ __ ] can
you imagine being the social media
manager for the police department like
you're like dude they're wild they're
having fun with it i think you have to
though right because all the dark [ __ ]
you have to like yeah they gotta soften
up their pr yeah a little just take a
photo
of a dead suspect and go was not
available for questioning freeze
[Laughter]
my cousin lives in the bay and he was uh
just looking for part-time jobs and he
was going through like the san francisco
like city listing
and if you're a poop picker-upper
because they have such a poop problem
it's 70 g's a year ooh that's a good job
you just go around
yeah how much do you got to pick up so
much poop all over the city yeah human
[ __ ]
yeah 70 g's a year to pick up poop it
got so bad that they made an app that
tells you where [ __ ] is oh brown maps
why would you send me your location
if you're like is it is it like you walk
around and then if you see [ __ ] you just
have to add it and so other people know
where it is yeah kind of like yeah you
think it is that it's like there's a car
accident yeah still here there yeah yeah
clear yeah yeah it got really bad
because there was a point where i think
uh they they like researched that they
were only within the san francisco city
there were only like two or three
places that a homeless person could
actually legally take a [ __ ]
because everything else they were like
nobody wanted them in their businesses
or in their bathroom even as a just
regular pedestrian going around san
francisco there's never any public
bathrooms right like the only time you
can use it is like you go to a
restaurant or something that's why
homeless people are like okay i'll just
[ __ ] here then i've seen a homeless
person [ __ ] in front of me before i've
seen a homeless restroom that's freaking
rough a homeless restaurant yeah they
make because they have nowhere to go
they make their own money the whole
restroom is just homeless
down the mountain like a twilight made
out of cardboard box yeah my uh so my
friends bought a property and we went to
go clean it up and it was it was an
encampment for homeless people and so we
kicked them all out and then um we
started looking around they made a
bedroom like in the front door of the
store and then on the side there was
this little cardboard hut we opened up
the hut and the wall and then the floor
is literally probably like a good like
five gallons of just poo um
holy [ __ ] yeah and it's not like like
you know you can like look at your poo
and see if you're healthy or not they
were not healthy like it was like goop
it was like you ever had a frosty dairy
dessert at wendy's yeah it was like not
anymore right
how did you guys clean all that out um
we cleaned everything except for that
part um what did you do you hired
someone yeah wow we paid the person some
random dude lived behind the gas station
next door um to watch their gas station
but uh we paid him freaking 20 bucks
uh to clean the poop and he's like okay
and he freaking did it for 20 bucks
20 bucks because that was a normal
homeless guy like not a pooper homeless
guy is that is that 20 bucks is that
where you ended up after haggling or you
offered him 20. he was 20 and he was
like okay matt was like
dude he was like 80 and you went nah 20.
okay he's like and i'll give you 15 off
of here
what a deal you guys are good guys i'll
give you a discount yeah
it was weird how they devised it so like
they had these cardboard walls and then
um there's a bunch of toilet paper just
being there's no trash can there's no
toilet so there's a pile of toilet paper
and then to like
to like make it so the poop didn't rise
up too high they pooped on piles of
clothes but once the pile closed too
full they would move it and they put
another pile of clothes um where they
could poop on interesting that's like
that's exactly like that's exactly the
video i just showed you guys yesterday
oh really oh that guy pooped on his own
sweater yeah there was a guy [ __ ] on
his own sweater outside of my studio and
then after he [ __ ] on the sweater is his
sweater was like full of just a big
amount of [ __ ] well he picked it up and
he slung it into the street and it
landed on all the cars man i'm not
donating clothes no more dude
i thought they were using it they're
just [ __ ] on it i'm here buying
clothes from goodwill i'm like huh what
are these stains looking weird they're
sick sweater though
brown tied up 15 it's not bad dude
that's how first of all how did you kick
the homeless people out what did you say
to get them to leave just tell them to
leave they're they're pretty civil yeah
they know it's like hey this is this is
this is not your problem you gotta go
they're like okay you have to do it a
few times but like uh they're pretty
resourceful their bedroom that they made
they found a mattress somehow they found
like an old like politician sign and
they used it as a canopy they tied at
one end with a string the other the
other end they ripped off a telephone
cord because there's a pay phone and
they tied it in such way where they
provided shade and then they found a
dresser somewhere and the dresser was
filled with a bunch of random crap
but it was literally that a dresser a
bed a freaking canopy did they take
anything with them um probably the
valuables um the stuff they left behind
where you didn't they're smart though
i've seen uh someone flip a shopping
cart over and then that was a grill oh
yes wow i was driving somewhere in la
just yesterday and they had these huge
tents under the freeway and they had
like a i know but they had like a
monster tent right but then you could
see inside of it they had like plants
inside of the tent and everything like
that i was like damn they got like a
greenhouse and everything is in a by
angel stadium there used to be this uh
this this homeless encampment in fact
there was a there was a government for
them they had a leader a president of
the encampment and they would negotiate
with the city of anaheim and then um if
there was crimes or anything they
wouldn't talk to them they would talk to
the leader and so that's fire dude
yeah dude they had negotiations and then
so they cleared them out and they they
had to negotiate with the leader before
they cleared everybody out it was on the
riverbed
it was nuts dude it's a whole government
[Music]
you